first it's do-or-die with the last place
in my semi-finals up for grabs from your
favorite Spanish restaurants over the
last couple years has been a real growth
in Spanish cooking in the UK there's so
much more to it than just Pilar the
Spanish are hugely proud of the culinary
heritage but also great innovators the
best Spanish restaurants combined
tradition and modern techniques to keep
you coming back for more
I've hand-picked two amazing Spanish
restaurants from hundreds of nominations
to battle it out what we NetScaler still
age from the heart of the capital its
Fino the established pioneer of modern
tapas in the UK are we their business
valleys we're sailin on their locking
horns with newcomer el pirata de tapas
in Notting Hill find the flag for a
whole new generation of Spanish cuisine
vamos vamos vamos we always call that
extra mile not just me
everybody not me at mass I'm going to
push both the Spanish contenders to the
very edge with three incredible
challenges
first it's every Reston's worst
nightmare 30 ravenous customers will
arrive an order all at the same time
stop number one is phyno a sleek and
stylish tapestry strand in central
London open seven years ago is owned by
two brothers salmon Eddie now the heart
boys have really helped change and
transform our perception on Spanish
cooking they have the most amazing
female head chef downstairs who runs her
kitchen with such military precision my
diners and I are in for one hell of a
treat
good to see where you know you yes
pretty well got him this is near miss
Barragan how are you Adelita and is a
team all-female not all the bosses are
female that's enough science and the
rest of them are terrified okay don't
put a finger out of place yeah really
surprise surprise brother Sam and Eddie
have restaurants in their blood raised
around their parents mr. starred
restaurant and hotel we grew up from a
pretty tender age in restaurants the
whole time literally from the moment we
could hold a knife or pour wine at
drinks parties and hand round the olives
in just seven years the brothers have
built their own empire of high-end
London restaurants renowned for their
vibrant atmosphere and fantastic service
he knows got an amazing energy consider
about 90 people at work and they're all
having three to four tap at each you
know it's something like 700 dishes
coming out of the kitchen so there's a
great buzz to the rhythm no three more
girls it tough intelligent head chef
Nieves has been cooking exquisite
classic tempers of phyno since it opened
many of our dishes inspired by her vast
groups any one goose the anchovies I
need one or two applause so we can
looking for the things the things one
more than three really is that what I
like in the plate that's perfection
last call a traditional Spanish
restaurant you know we're not trying to
break the mold what we like to do is
just source the best ingredients we come
and cook them simply so the secret is
just to let that duck egg yolk oh it's
delicious I mean who would have thought
that beaten for beans to be so exciting
that's one portion but I suppose it's
one Taphouse portion that shared isn't
it why I wouldn't share that anyway no
this woman is truly gifted could her
incredible passion take phyno all the
way in this competition my dad is gonna
be driving just under five minutes from
now
nervous I can feel that adrenaline yeah
from here I can see it pulsating through
those veins you can probably do this
standing on your head alone with no one
in the kitchen
however yeah just just do what you do
best and good luck thank you